KeyMe allows you to instantly make duplicate
copies of your keys by storing a digital copy
of your keys so you never get locked out again....
and it'll open your beer
And the Marshall Dicycle is an electric motorcycle
concept that doubles as amplifiers when instruments
are plugged in.
Vsauce! Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
The cafe latte printer allows customers to
drink their own face. Let's Cafe - is a kiosk
in taiwanese convenience stores that is offering
customers the opportunity to print any picture
taken from their phone instantly onto the
top of their latte. It works by dusting the
image with an edible powder with a computer-controlled
print head.
The LiveMap helmet was created by russian
inventors to make a motorcycle helmet with
built in navigation. The helmet creates translucent
full color images and text in the visor giving
the rider the ability to check speed, time,
and get directions without taking their eyes
off the road like traditional navigation.
It's only slightly larger than a normal helmet
and adjusts depending on the lighting outside.
If the indiegogo amount is achieved they plan
to sell them for around $2000.
Researchers at North Carolina State University
have created a device that controls cockroaches
using an Xbox Kinect. They created an interface
that sends the roach on a predetermined track
by using a computer to plot its course. Researchers
wire sensors to the roach's external sensory
organs causing it to move forward and small
charges in the neural tissue tricks the roach
into thinking its antennae are hitting a barrier
causing it to turn.
Scientists in Japan cloned this mouse from
only a drop of blood of the donors tail!
Tokyoflash created the Kisai watch that lets
users know whether or not they are intoxicated
through the use of a built in breathalyzer.
By blowing into a hole located in the side
of the watch for five seconds the watch glows
green if it detects no alcohol, yellow if
alcohol is detected but you are in the legal
limit, and red if you are legally drunk. The
watch also has a built in sobriety test that
asks the user to stop a moving line at a certain
point on the screen.
Sensoria are a pair of socks that are able
to track the way people walk. Developed by
Heapsylon, by using a bluetooth enabled anklet
in conjunction with the socks the sensors
in the socks transmit the data to a computer
or smartphone. Sensoria can determine improper
walking or running habits or if the foot is
landing at an unsafe angle during particular
activities.
WI-Vi is a prototype handheld device that
researchers at MIT have created in order to
see through walls. Users will be able to point
the device at walls and see anything moving
on the other side. WiVi works by emitting
wifi signals at the wall where some of those
signals bounce off of the moving objects on
the other side and back to the device. Wivi
could be used in multiple applications including
aiding police and rescue workers or creating
verybetter motion controlled gaming systems.
Archaeologists have recently discovered that
flowers have been used at funerals for 13,000
years.
This self-burying robot was presented by the
Carnegie Mellon University Robotics Institute
in May of 2013. The plans to use self burying
robots range from mining to military applications.
This robot is able to travel to its location
in one mode and then bury itself in another.
Shown in this video digging through various
things such as rice, sand, flour, and sugar,
but it's still in the developmental stages
and they're trying to make more efficient
versions.
This bike helmet is made from recycled paper
pulp. It was created by students from the
Royal College of Art in London by making a
pulp out of old newspapers they mixed with
an adhesive, pigment, and organic additive.
They claim to be rain proof for up to six
hours and can be recycled again after being
used to make more helmets. Though wearing
these may be better than no protection it's
still unclear the actual safety of the helmets.
The Termes Project is developing self-organizing
simple robots building 3-D structures. Based
upon the building abilities of termites - the
robot is able to navigate, lift blocks and
build structures much larger than itself and
the researchers at Harvard University are
looking into ways to further develop automated
construction.
Finally, Minsu Kim's Living food project is
a concept involving food that moves on the
plate and in your mouth by building on developments
in synthetic biology.
I'm going to leave you with a barrel of ping
pong balls on fire. And as always - thanks
for watching.